Mark: Hiya!
Hiya-hiya.
Hiya.
Ha-doink!
(Uhhhh)
Ethan: Oh no, my tummy. (D:)
Tyler: *annoyed* Quit shoving your red rocket in the camera's face.
M: Why?
T: *exasperated inhale* Why do you have two of them?
And why are they in my face?
M: Imma-Imma freak of nature. Don't ya love it, baby? (0.o)
T: They already have white things comin' out of 'em. (that's what she said)
M: Ohh yeeah. Lemme-lemme engage Turbo Mode.
Bbrrrrbrbrbrrbrbrrrrr- (you're using rockets as scissors. how intelligent.)
*laughs* Owwww...
*more laughs*
E: What'd you do??
M: I Turbo Mode into my balls (it was your decision mark)
*laughing continues*
(Mark's going out to hunt some deeeeer)
*dubstep*
(You're terrorizing poor Tyler again)
(and this time he can't breathe)
(do y'all feel bad for him yet?)
(boing)
*the deer man frolics in the field*
(aww how nice, it's another fan! :D)
*music dies down*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Deer Man, a game
where either you or I are a deer
man, and either you or I
are shooting either you or I
Now if that sounds confusing, (yes it does) that's because
I don't know what the hell I'm talking about
Oh! Oh, woooow!
*narrative dialogue creeps out mark*
Okay
This is as fast as I can run! *gasp*
I'm incredibly out of shape! (we've heard it before...)
Please don't find me - Oh, I guess I'm
already going left. Wait a minute,
Are you trying to tell me which way to go?
I'm gonna go... straight ahead. (there's our lovable non-tutorial watching mark)
Because I'm a baller!
Shot caller! Ain't nobody
gonna tell me what to do because I have no idea
what I'm doing. Oh, is that a cemetery?
Oh shit. *turns somber*
Well, this is not a place to run.
I hear voices in my head...
(it's the narrative dialogue mark)
Wait, WUT?!
Did I? Is that what this is?
Ooh, oh, okay. Well that's... (an antler, not a deer leg)
Well that's handy dandy! I got one of five.
I think I see another antler over there.
*ND* (short for narrative dialogue)
Oh yeah, let's go into it!
Going inside! Hello
*ND*
Ah, hello. A letter.
*reads the letter*
Alrighty, then.
Wooden box was locked, but I managed to open it.
Who are you talking to!?
I just got here! Who peed this
message into the snow? *edit jump* I have no idea what you
were waiting for, but it couldn't have been me! (or was it? don't put anything against us mark)
Okay, gonna open it. Somehow, somehow,
I manged to open it. *breath* is that an
axe? Can I use it to kill the deer man?
If I remember, i took the axe to...
Kill somebody? Okay, so i got the axe,
and i got five of five antlers,
So I'm assuming I can open this box.
I'm ready for ya! Open up, open up!
Open up!
*ND* (all that for some clothes. fantastic.)
Is it the Deer Man? Are these the Deer Man's clothes?
Does the Deer Man love button-ups?
Does the Deer Man look d-like-like-
-dldlkalikdlkldlala
Like to look good on a Saturday evening?
Alright, so am I done?
Have I run enough?
That doesn't sound good-
*ND*
Uh, I dunno, what is what?
OH! Hi!
ruuuUU-OKAY ARRIGHT YOU DON'T HAVE TO TELL ME!!!
Da fuck!
*ND*
I CAN'T? WHY NOT?
WHY WOULDN'T I LOOK BACK? I dunno where -
Oooooh god I'm dead I'm dead i'm deeaad
i'm dead i'm dead, I don't know where to hide...
How could I not look back?
It's a fucking Deer Man!
I'm sorry I looked in your panty drawer! (snooper dooper mark)
I APOLOGIZE!! (you'd better)
Uuuh god, okay, oh-ohOH JESUS-
Alrighty then! Wooooah nelly-nelly-ally-allie-alli-ALLE!
Ah, fuck, lock it up.
Lock it up, LOCK IT UP (this sounds a lot like fuck off)
There we go. Jeezums-
Ohhh ma gawd, I done bad
Hi.
How're you doin'?
Hullo.
*quietly* ok-ay.
Alrighty then.
*loud knocking* Oh - [gibberish] FUCK
*ND*
Should you? Oh, is that a good idea?
Well, let's just take that chance-
Annnd GUN IT
AHHHH
Okay are we fine okay I think we're fine..
OH GODAMMIT
AHHH *voice cracks like mark's true prepubescent self*
Aw, I'm dead. I'm dead.
I'm going back in... Nah, it's not gon-
What the fuck.
*Mark reads*
BECUZ I - I LIKE DE WOODS
*ND*
*Mark's concerned face*
Alrighty, then.
*more ND*
*and even more ND*
(i'll just be quiet now)
Did I? Oh. 'Kay.
*bang*
Okay~
(it's "he'd", not "he's")
Awww....
*ND*
Oh, jeez.
Oh, jeez!
Well I mean you gotta do what ya gotta do...
if your family's starving alone in the woods.
*ND*
*Mark reads*
*gunshot* Fuck.
Hello. Uh-oh!
Well that don't seem good!
Hey!
Run TOWARDS the bullets
Okay. Wait where you going?
You cowards.
*ND*
Oh jeez.
Did the deer man get shot?
I'm pretty sure this is where I discovered
that the deer man got shot
Oh...
Yeah.
That's a big dude
Yeah...Well I mean, kind of a bad idea to
Run around with a deer head
*Mark reads*
What is happening?!
Oh!
I didn't even see him.
Oh~
Oh jeez!
Don't mind me I'm just gonna
pick up these antlers. Oh god
you're so cute!
Ugh you're so cute!
Ohh my goodness I can't even run.
I'm so emotionally devastated by
this guy I just met that was in the woods with a deer mask.
He connected to me on
an emotional level.
What a good guy! I mean, admittedly-
*ND*
Oh.
Well! Guess it's time to go find me a deer head.
Oh man! I know that's not the lesson to
take out of this but that is quite a leap.
I- I need to say this: I totally get the
message of- of protecting nature and
connecting *bumps mic*
No I-
O-oh
Oh!
Yeah!
That's the moral of the story!
Yeah! I'm the deer man! You're the deer man!
We're all the deer man! Alright uh- admittedly,
let me get my skepticism out of here let
me pull out my skepticism body
Hprblblbllbruh
Hey! It seems really like a bad idea to
dong the moniker of the deer man after you
only met one time in the woods, and he
seemed pretty crazy, considering that he
probably; number one he had a family.
Remember that whole story about how he had a family?
He probably let them starve because he
didn't want to kill any deer so his
family starved. They only had one meal
left, now they have NO meals left, because
they're dead. And they're buried in those
woods next to the deer man but it's okay
cause he ran around with a deer mask on?
To stop hunters at the expense of his life?
And now that inspired you so much
that that's what you're gonna do with your
life, and that's logical?! But okay! Alright I'm gonna just- Okay
I'm stepping back in was ok but other than
hughalngiarunairfbnhguth
Okay. But other than
that– I think I can- I think I can accept
this and I have an idea of what I'm
gonna do about this.
I have an idea of what I'm gonna do. I–
Will be the deer man..
*Villainous laughter*
Semi-Darkiplier: There's Deermen  in these woods.
Somewhere, lurking dark in the forest,
there's a deerman...
and I'm gonna find him... (he's right next to you mark)
*gibberish* I'm doing it, look at me
I'm like..
Whoa.. What the duck...
*laughing*
Jesus!
Tyler, say something
Tyler: ARGH I'M IN A TREE! (gobble gobble)
*Laughter*
Mark: Not what I was thinking you're gonna say.
*gigglish* oh my gawd...
Mark: Oh my gawd...
*Tyler's interpretive deer noises*
*arrow whistling*
Mark: OH!
Mark's "normal" eating noises (hablphphph)
*smooch*
*Deep emotional thoughts* I am the deer man... (enlightened markimoo)
*starts doing things to the former Deer Man's corpse*
*trippy stuff happens*
*Wheeew*
Tyler: Right in the ass
Mark: Oh come on what, wh-
T: YOU HAVE TO EAT HIS HEART. (savagery)
M: What have you done???
What have you done.... (x2)
What have you done?!(x3)
What have you done :( (x4)
Hunter!
You've killed this poor unsuspecting creature... (and you've stuffed Ethan in there)
*Patting the Deer* This poor beautiful creature here...
Woman: I-I gotta feed my family!
his face that he had back to Spain this
is your face
this isn't a deer this is some this is a
deer man. You killed a man now you must become
the deer man. You bet you didn't know
this was part of it you're gonna put
this on we're going to shoot you.
Oh shit! Do you feel the deer man
inside you? "Yes." Do you feel one with the forest?
Yes! (x3) You're so free and in touch
with nature. Oh it's glorious.
You have to do this. Your family–ok here's your
motivation: your family's starving it's
the dead of winter... you had–
*unintelligible* (Mark continues)
No. It's the dead of winter. This is your
child. Your child is hungry.
he's grown big and strong but you're
feeding him– But you have to feed him. The
only deer left in the forest is right
there standing in front of you. "Ok" you
have to kill that deer to feed
your family is with this."Is it a (Swedish) deer?" We
can assume it is yes. Ok ok give it up
Swedish deer, it's a reindeer. "Daddy kill the deer!"
Yeah he's starting. Every missed shot
is another child gone. The stakes are
so high here.
Oh! What have you done?! (x3)
Oh no! This precious creature... Was it worth
killing this deer to feed your family?
Here's the surprise: this is no deer it's
a lady under there.
It's a human being. You're a murder you know
what you have to do? *unintelligible* No but you're gonna
stay right here and you're gonna put on
this costume we're going to shoot at you!
"Yay!!" Cool? Great. Alright. So for you you're
alone in the woods you have no family,
you ate them to survive. Now you have no other options.
Both your legs have been chewed off
because you had to eat him to survive. *Intelligible sounds* Mark: Yes.
Have a little bit of a handicap but
that's okay you're not gonna let it stop you.
Your will to survive is so strong that
you ate all of your babies. (um what)
Lady:  They were good.
They were good, they were very fresh.
Yeah, it was sad though you're very sad.
So you have to kill one more thing in order to survive.
*Intelligible sounds with Mark waving hands*
Mark: OH
Ethan: Oh yes!
*crowd applauses*
Mark: What have you done?
You're starv- you're-you're numbly!
You have no legs!
Eat! Eat! Eat em'!
OHHH
Oh gee- oh *oh's continues*
Eat da heart!
Okay, you have no remorse.
I don't think you can be the deer man.
Yeah I'm pretty sure..
Alright..
Just gonna carry a carcass away here.
So the next one is, we have two bows actually.
IMMNA be the deer man!
*crowd cheers*
I'm ready! *batman voice* I'm the deer man.
Here's the deal: everyone's gonna have a chance to shoot me.
Got it?
So if you hit me, transfer your safety
officer uniform to the next person and
then wail on me with reckless abandon,
and then we'll come up my corpse y'all
feast, we'll have a great time
Sound good? Crowd: Yes. Mark: Alright.
You couldn't hit me~
Even if you tryy~
*Intelligible sounds*
Crowd: Oh! Oh!
*Mark continues to annoy*
*Crowd cheers*
*Mark limps*
*Crowd laughs*
(oh how I wish I was there)
*Crowd continues to laugh and cheer*
You have almost got him!
GO! KILL HIM!
*Mark annoys again*
KILL HIM.
Destroy him! Eat em'!
*lmao mark*
*beats down Mark with the bow*
Immna stand still.
(show-off)
*pew*
*Mark magically dodges the attack*
*Crowd is amazed and shrieks because of his awesomeness*
*more shooting and dodging*
Mark: Miss me.
*PEW*
*BOOM*
*Screams of achievement and success*
*Applause*
EAT EM'.
Mark: Oh geez. Oh no god.
Don't eat me please :(
*Markimoose loosing sanity*
*Mating season already?*
(Boi I wish I was there)
*More jerking off*
*Boom*
Mark: AH!
Ahh